Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an American superhero comedy film
called “Zoom”. Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
Thirty years ago, a team of five superheroes
called the Zenith fought interstellar criminals
and saved the earth. The team leader was a
superhero named Zoom. He was an ordinary man
before being recruited by the US government
for a special program. He had the ability
to run faster than flash. The team also
consisted of Zoom’s elder brother Concussion
who was just as good as him. When the earth was
at risk of being invaded, the American military,
led by General Larraby, sought to enhance
the team's powers using an experimental form
of radiation called "Gamma-13".
The group was blasted with the ray
which made Zoom faster and stronger but created a
psychotic break in Concussion. It made him angry,
unreasonable, and evil. Believing
that Zoom and the team betrayed him,
Concussion killed three of his teammates. In
the end, Zoom defeated him and threw him into
an interdimensional portal to never return.
However, over the years after that, Zoom lost
his powers slowly and returned to his old life
as Jack, a mechanic living in California.
Now, after thirty years, a scientist on the Zenith
Project, Dr. Grant finds out that Concussion,
who had entered a dimensional rift, is on a return
trajectory. He has not died or aged because of his
speed through space-time. The scientists have all
the reasons to believe that he is just as powerful
and is returning to take revenge on his brother.
However, Zoom has become accustomed to his life as
Jack and has long lost his powers. Because of
this, General Larraby wants to recruit children
with special powers and train them to fight
Concussion when he returns. However, they only
have twelve days to do so before his arrival.
The only person fit to train the special children
is Zoom himself. The General is sure that he will
not cooperate, so he orders Grant to bring him to
the base one way or the other. Then, we see the
former superhero Captain Zoom for the first time.
After being retired, he is known as Jack.
He uses whatever power he has left to froth
his coffee with his fingers. Grant and
a psychologist on the Zenith Project,
Dr. Marsha come to recruit Jack for the mission.
Jack thinks the idea is crazy because they do not
need another set of superheroes. Sensing that
he doesn’t want to be a part of the mission,
Grant shoots him with a tranquilizer gun and
knocks him out. The General and Grant have
decided to keep the return of Concussion a secret
from Jack because they believe it will make him
emotional and fog his critical thinking.
Then, we are introduced to the youngest member
of the team of superheroes who are yet to be
recruited. She is a six-year-old girl named
Cindy who has superhuman strength. She can pick up
and throw a grown person with no effort. Cindy has
been using her power to fight bullies but now
wants to audition to be in the superhero team.
Next, is a sixteen years old highschooler named
Summer. She has the power of psychokinesis and can
move a person or an object using just her mind.
She can also read people’s minds to some extent.
Because Summer is always alone at school,
she is considered an outcast by many.
Hence, to try to fit in, she wants to
audition for the superhero team.
Then, there is seventeen-year-old Dylan who can
be invisible at his will. He uses the power to
outsmart his teachers but always gets in trouble.
Lastly, twelve-year-old Tucker has the most unique
power. He can blow up the size of any part of his
body and make himself giant. In the training base,
Jack gains consciousness and is told that he will
get half a million dollars if he accepts to train
the newbies but if he declines, he will be
sent to prison under a false accusation.
Jack accepts the offer but he still insists that
the world doesn’t need superheroes anymore.
Following that, he officially meets Dr. Marsha who
is his biggest fan. She collects the first edition
of all of Zenith comics and is obsessed with Zoom.
Jack sees the candidates for the next team of
superheroes and is shocked that they are all kids.
He jokes if they are auditioning for the spelling
bee but Grant claims that all the kids who are
participating have been given a unique power
at birth. According to Dr. Marsha, they will have
to naturally enhance the children’s power because
the risk with Gamma-13 is too high.
The kids show their special talent;
some blink too fast while the others are farting
machines. By the end of the day, Cindy, Summer,
Dylan, and Tucker are selected to be trained.
Meanwhile, Concussion will be on earth in nine
more days. The General and Grant are delighted
that they were able to recruit the best children
in such a short period but they are skeptical
if Jack will be able to train them in time.
The General is ready to dose the kids
with Gamma-13, without considering
the effect it will have on their health.
At first, the recruited children do not take Jack
seriously and think that he is just a random old
dude. But then, Dr. Marsha gives them a lesson on
the history of Team Zenith and reveals that Jack
is actually Captain Zoom. The youngest two kids
start to look up to him but the oldest Dylan is
still skeptical. The scientists, including Jack,
check the extent of the children’s powers by
making them use their respective abilities.
Cindy is always dressed in pretty pink
dresses, even while carrying tons of weight.
Jack finds her annoying but the little girl
talks to him every chance she gets. Dylan,
on the other hand, is the most troublesome
of them all. He disappears while they try to
evaluate his powers. The facility develops a new
alert called “code Dylan” just to catch him.
One day, after evaluation, Jack asks Dr.
Marsha what they are training the kids for
but she dismisses him. The truth is that even
she doesn’t know about Concussion’s return.
In a meeting with the General and other
officials from the military, she presents
the results of their last few evaluations. It
is revealed that the children are capable of
channeling an unfathomable amount of energy but
currently, they are subconsciously suppressing
their full abilities. Jack tries to enter the
meeting but is escorted out by security.
The following day, Grant takes the kids
and Jack to a lab where they meet Mr. Pebb,
an AI robot that was built to keep team Zenith
company. With Pebb’s help, Jack takes the children
to a room where their old space saucer is kept.
He secretly loads the kids up in the flying
vehicle and takes them out for a ride. They fly
to Wendy's drive-through and get themselves lunch.
Everything goes well but the event makes the
news and people start to believe that the earth
is being invaded by ice-cream-eating aliens.
The scientists at the base find out about Jack’s
little trip but they can take no action against
Captain Zoom himself. That night, Jack is woken
up by little Cindy in a rabbit costume. She had
a bad dream and wants to sleep in Jack’s room
for the rest of the night. He feels bad for the
little girl and allows her to sleep on the couch
bolted to the wall. Cindy thanks him and pulls
the couch out with little to no effort.
The following day, the scientists put the kids in
a room filled with hundreds of paintball launchers
to train them to dodge bullets. After that, they
train on treadmills and use their powers on a
one-on-one session with Jack. Although they are
getting better at using their specific strengths,
they still have a lot to improve. By the end of
the day, they are covered in paint and bruises and
are exhausted. Dylan comments that no one in the
camp cares about them and Jack is only using them
for money. When Cindy asks him if that is true,
he neither confirms nor denies the claim. Later,
Jack goes to meet Dylan in a cell where
he is being kept for trying to escape.
He tells Dylan how he was recruited at a young
age and was made to train with his brother.
Dylan realizes that Concussion, who he knows
from the comics is also a real person and
is none other than Jack’s older brother. Jack
is visibly uncomfortable talking about him so
he asks Grant to let them both out of the cell.
In the next one-on-one session with Dylan,
Jack realizes that he may have an additional
special power. He asks Dylan to close his eyes
and visualize where Summer is right now. As the
boy focuses, he can see her dancing in her room.
It turns out that the power is called mind-sight
and is the rarest power a human being can have.
Jack praises Dylan for channeling it at such
a young age and declares him the leader of the
team. Later, we see Jack and Dr. Marsha together
talking about the training. Jack compliments her
hard work, making her blush. She has always liked
and idolized him which he thinks is adorable.
In the next scene, Grant and the General
are at the location where the portal to
another dimension lies. They assume that
Concussion is going to emerge in the location
and hence make their soldiers guard the place.
Grant plans to use the kids as a distraction
and utilize a sonic net to catch Concussion.
The net will force him to concuss and hence
will turn him back to normal in an instant. When
only forty-eight hours are left for his arrival,
Jack throws a party for the kids since they have
worked hard the past few days. Dylan and Summer
dance together while the others watch them. Soon,
Marsha and Jack also join them. However, their
fun is ruined when Grant interrupts and orders
them to shut down the party immediately.
Jack sees the soldiers bringing in
equipment for the gamma 13 inducing process.
He registers that they are about to hurt the
kids like they hurt his team thirty years ago.
He retaliates to the General but the man
is adamant about his decision. At midnight,
Jack goes to the children’s room and wakes them
up. He plans to secretly make them run away before
the General can hurt them. They are brought to
an electric vent which leads to a secret room.
There, the kids finally get their superhero
names; Dylan is Mega Boy, Summer is Wonder,
Tucker is Houdini, and Cindi is Princess.
Suddenly, Dylan gets a vision from the
other room and finds out that the real
mission that officials are working on
is to eliminate Concussion when he returns to
the earth. When Jack finds out that his brother
is alive, he almost doesn’t believe him.
After asking the kids to remain safe, he runs
to find out the truth. The General confirms
that Concussion is in fact alive and will be
back in less than two hours. Jack insists that the
kids will never be able to go against Concussion
and urges the General to abort the mission. But
he is locked in a cell so the project would run
smoothly. Somewhere else, Marsha has found
the kids and is bringing them to the Grant.
On her way, she blows the guards away with
her rainbow breath, revealing that she also
has superpowers. Then the group gets Jack out of
the cell and flies away in the space saucer.
At the same time, the dimensional portal opens
and Concussion is about to land on earth.
The Saucer reaches the location. Jack asks the
kids to stay inside and goes out to meet his
brother. They come face to face and almost do not
recognize each other. Concussion hasn’t aged a day
since they last met while Jack has turned old and
weak. He tries to calm his evil brother down but
Concussion pushes him with an extraordinary force
and sends him flying. Then, the kids, who have now
completely turned into Superheroes arrive at the
scene, only to be made fun of by Concussion.
When he is distracted, the General launches
the web that is supposed to catch him.
But Concussion easily diverts its direction
towards Cindy. As she is about to get hit,
Jack regains his powers and saves her in a
second. Following that, he runs to the lab,
puts on his protective gear, and returns to the
location, all in less than five seconds. The
Zenith team is told that if Concussion is placed
in the middle of the web that was thrown earlier,
there is a high chance he will turn back to his
normal self. Dylan uses his power to distract
Concussion while Summer launches several rocks
at him. Then, Tucker, using his bloated stomach
throws him to the air and Cindy hits him
with a pole. At last, Marsha uses her breath
to push him into the web. Jack, who has now turned
into Zoom, keeps his brother inside the web. In
only a few seconds, Concussion returns back to
his normal self and stops being aggressive.
Zoom asks Dr. Grant to come with them and forms
a new Zenith team consisting of himself Marsha,
Dr. Grant, Concussion, Dylan, Summer,
Tucker, and Cindy. In the last scene,
we see them flying away in a saucer.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.